After studying nearly 500 crocodiles in Costa Rica’s
Palo Verde National park, scientists found
something odd: males outnumbered females
4 to 1 among younger crocs.
The number is even more startling
because a warming climate should be
skewing the ratio in the opposite direction.
The mean low temperature in Palo Verde
has risen 2.5 degrees in less than 20 years.
Since sex in crocs is determined by nest temperature
during incubation, female hatchlings should be
outnumbering males by 2 to 1.
So what’s causing over-masculinization
in these animals?
Researchers think one potential source
is fish farms surrounding the park.
The tilapia raised on these farms
are fed chow laced with a synthetic hormone
called Methyltestosterone or MT.
This steroid is used to transform female tilapia
into males, which are more lucrative
because they grow faster.
MT found in croc blood and egg yolk samples
confirms the Palo Verde crocs
have been exposed to the steroid.
To test if MT is altering sex ratios, researchers
dabbed varying strengths of the chemical onto
alligator eggs and then incubated them
at a temperature that should yield only females.
They found that among the eggs with the highest
dosage of MT, 60% developed into males.
The experiment confirms that MT does have
a masculinizing effect.
Exactly how the Palo Verde crocs take up MT
isn’t clear but scientist suspect that some tilapia
escape the farm and get eaten by crocs,
which absorb the steroid and store it in fat.
Females produce eggs and pass it on to their offspring.
Researchers say the MT-tainted tilapia isn’t likely
to be a health problem for humans because the
hormone doesn’t accumulate in muscle,
which is the part of the fish
that are cut into fillets.
But evidence that MT is loose in the environment
is worrying to some researchers since
it’s been shown that low levels of male hormones
can be detrimental to pregnant women.
Few tilapia farms in the US use MT-laced food,
but its use is widespread in the tropics.
The hormone even turned up far from
the tilapia farm surrounding Palo Verde—
with a croc population in an entirely different
river system more than 100 km away.
This suggests that contaminated crocs are
migrating or that MT could be coming downstream
from city sewers.
The steroid has medical uses and body-builders
are known to abuse it.
So scientists are branching out to study
other regions and they plan to measure MT’s affect
on more crocs and gators.
They want to nail down exactly how the steroid affects
reproduction, behavior, and if the contamination
is doing harm to other creatures in ecosystems.